est ce qu'on a vu laurent pas fait faire
un tu pue du cul à ma maman
est en 2017 principe est simple avoir
quelqu'un au téléphone et dire un
maximum de fois tu peux du cul et ma
maman qui l'a eu au téléphone regardes
et tu le feras tu pue du cul ma mère
alors
chanté on va clara petits prix de la
tomate on perde
[Rires]
testeurs
oui ça va ma petite poulette
du pdq
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toi tu es plus du q
[Musique]
& start et plus du tube pop
c'est plus que toi même tu pues déçu
hester
la mort autant bracelet dossier
c'est ce qui nous caractérise chaîne à
la courtoisie
batié c'était magnifique lol on en train
de s'occuper de son compte twitter
t'inquiète pas ce sera fait drôle je
suis pas inquiet janvier prochain est ce
qu'on a vu laurent baffie créer une
grosse embrouille entre julien lepers et
patrice laffont oui oui oui mais ça
va vite et dans la grande barca on vient
jouer ou l'invité de mai d'écrire en un
mot une personnalité qu'on lui montrer
et à cause de la
il ya eu une embrouille entre julien
lepers est passé
patrice patrice alors attends attends de
temps avant de répondre on a reçu
patrice laffont dans la grande d'arqués
en octobre dernier a pris à la regarde
et on l'a fait la même chose vous
regarde
plusieurs personnalités vous allez
devoir me balancer un défaut sur elle
julien lepers vient le père se
[Musique]
[ __ ]
[Rires]
tu as remarqué je suis le seul à partir
de leur disent pas d'où vient lambeaux
il pas pourquoi vient embrouille
pourquoi c'est gratuit je ne sais pas
mais ça c'est gratuit tant il ya des
millions de gens qui regardent salazie
pas me laisser faire c'était donc eu les
crises en direct une embrouille avec lui
patrice bonjour bonsoir je m'appelle
julien lepers est aussi vrai que je
m'appelle julien lepers je voudrais que
tu es le courage de décrocher son
téléphone et de me dire pourquoi tu me
traite d'enculé devant tout le monde
devant des millions de gens dans les
émissions de cyril hanouna
plutôt bien la vérité parce que je sais
pourquoi la traiter comme ça regarde tu
là le père
pourquoi tu t'en fous enfin c'est ce que
tu attends attends pas mr bah non tu va
trop vite il faut revenir sur julien
lepers a très bien le perse je m'en fous
non alors biancu laissé pour nous pour
[Applaudissements]
julien lepers du doigt le perse [ __ ]
tant de gens ont fait appel
la portée pour calmer le jeu tout
[Musique]
l'histoire
patrice c'est ton copain ton ami ton
frère
je suis un battant
des voix
à mes plus grands fous rires on l'avait
fait réserve d'après ok ce bon client
non mais c'est très olé fait la semaine
d'après parce qu'après c'est devenu à la
mode et pascal légitimus
mais pourquoi qu'est ce que j'ai pas le
perdre c'était extraordinaire est ce
qu'on a vu laurent baffie confessé en
direct avoir partagé la même femme qu'un
grand animateur télé non oui même si
alors je sais pas comment expliquer
cette séquence de tpm paix sociale qui
gêne et je ne peux pas l'expliquer sont
choqués donc le mieux ses deux
amis
regardent si vous deviez animer une
émission sur sa laquelle j'aimerais bien
faire qui veut gagner des millions
pourquoi parce que c'est une mécanique
formidable et je me verrais bien là
dedans une fois pour essayer ça marrant
je dois dire que je serai au lamentin et
va proposer même à jean pierre foucault
vous et jean pierre poupart qui lâchera
pas sa place jean pire mais il est très
bon dans l'exercice et il est excellent
mais jean-pierre il partage c'est un
amour il pourrait beaucoup et je sais je
fus baiser sa femme
[Rires]
evil et bim colombe à seville ta famille
l'aurait alors menacé
[Rires]
jean brajon pierre bien sûr mon analyse
la
voie que répartie n'est pas synonyme de
vérité bon et bien sûr est exact
de jean-pierre exactement est ce que tu
te rappelles aussi quand appelé tir
ardisson direct nancy on sida premier
rives non marc castanet parce que tu
mettais toujours quelle journée oui oui
bonsoir
monsieur soit alors regardez il appelait
tirard du son direct et ses rivaux des
petites et ses mythes oui laurent voilà
un passage des aurillacois et c'est vrai
qu'il mettait toujours un cadre avec
thierry dessus et il appuiera pour la
première garde mais ses coups de gueule
en connaissez réaction et puis là il a
fait une visite au salon de
l'agriculture est thierry on s'est raté
[Rires]
jean meyer tablette a
[Musique]
confirmé lundi à l'ehpad 1
je suis avec cyril hanouna thélème bien
oui
je voulais que les gens
[Applaudissements]